today we're going to be speaking with
lily geismer who's an associate
professor of history at claremont
mckenna college and also author of the
book left behind the democrats failed
attempt to solve inequality really great
having you on today i appreciate your
time
oh thank you so much for the invitation
so i mean i think an interesting place
to start or a logical place to start
would be
most of my audience i'm sure would agree
that at least the rhetoric and the
promises of the democratic party
relative to the republican party would
seem more likely to reduce inequality
and to sort of level the economic
disparities that we see in the united
states and yet to a great degree it
really hasn't happened and we could talk
about why that's the case we could say
well it's it's
despite every good intention it's simply
republican obstructionism and sort of
shift the blame elsewhere and and and
take that approach but you take a
different approach in the book can you
can you talk a little bit about the way
you see what you call the this failed
attempt to deal with inequality
absolutely and i think that one of the
issues which you've um
identified and is not and this is not to
say that the republican i think the
republican party is blameless in efforts
to address inequality but i think so
often there's an effort to just sort of
say
this it's all it putting putting blame
solely on the republican party for its
policies and one of the things i really
wanted to understand is that um why
inequity has increased so dramatically
in the united states
since the real since the 1970s but
especially since 1990s and to understand
the democratic party's
efforts to address it and why those
efforts didn't work and what i
came to
largely is the fact that um the
democratic party increasingly starting
in the 1970s started to
use try to use the private sector and
the market as a tool to address
inequality and what i want to understand
want to understand and what the book
addresses is is why those kinds of
programs um don't work or why that
approach um actually led to shrinking
the social welfare state and compounding
inequality and and really contributing
to many of the kind of problems we are
seeing today yeah so can you give us
like one
example that might be an easy easily
relatable one in terms of the idea of
how to use the private sector what was
done and why it did not work
well there's a lot and the book sort of
tracks a bunch of them yeah um one of
the really clear ones is um the efforts
to use programs like micro enterprise or
micro finance which is this very popular
tool in um especially 1990s and really
beginning in the 1980s um people like
bill clinton had the idea and so for
those of you who aren't familiar with
what micro enterprise is it's the idea
of kind of giving small loans um to poor
people to start their own businesses um
and so you start sort of micro
entrepreneurs um it was first
experimented with um in the global south
especially in bangladesh by someone
named muhammad yunus um and the clintons
um in arkansas in the 80's become really
enamored in this with this program and
that you could kind of take what's a
private sector tool of micro under
entrepreneurship and starting your own
business um and that could actually be a
replacement for
traditional forms of welfare and
particularly forms of um of of kind of
cash assistance so that's what bill
clinton touts and the idea is that i
mean it removes the kind of social
safety net and leaves leaves poor people
up to the kind of whims of the market so
the way it was sold is kind of like turn
your hobby into a business so you can
instead of needing sort of the the um
support of government you can kind of be
your own entrepreneur and that's one
kind of program that was adopted um i
can give a couple other examples too but
this idea of another one would be kind
of turning to um
there's um in terms of housing the the
program which comes you know is hope six
which is um uh which is a public private
um mixed income program so taking away
like the kind of big public housing prog
big public housing developments um in
chicago the most iconic ones are
cabrini green um or the robert taylor
homes an intense ins instead turning to
these more kind of um
the kind of townhouse style developments
um that can kind of earn a profit um and
will um at the same time that will help
people and so that's another kind of
approach that com that comes in that is
addressing this kind of critical problem
of housing um but in a way that's kind
of using the private sector um the book
also looks at things like charter
schools as a key example of this too
which is a kind of mechanism using the
mechanisms of the market um so charter
schools though at least how the
democratic party in the 90s promoted it
was not about making a profit but was
about using the techniques of the
private sector
to make
make public schools more efficient and
accountable and so all of those are kind
of efforts to kind of address these what
what traditionally all of those
welfare
housing schools
the idea is that those are kind of
critical components of of what the
public sector should be doing and what
we rely on government to do and instead
you're kind of taking mechanisms of the
private sector to do that and it seems
at least in some cases when these
mechanisms or initiatives are created
it's also used as a justification
to cut
other programs and and
it seems that it ends up being sort of
zero sum in a sense
yeah that's i think that's absolutely
right so one of the things i look at the
book is there's a lot of this language
that these are win-wins um because in a
lot of this a lot of the ideas is that
it's um and another kind of critical
program that i look at is like efforts
to kind of um
turn treat um poor communities like
their parts of the global south and kind
of bring corporate investment to them so
like the same way that globalization was
working internationally they used to
bring private sector investment and
that's like helps the community brings
jobs brings walgreens um but at the same
and also helps companies like walgreens
gain a profit and so it's a win-win but
it's actually in many ways a
zero sum
in the fact that like who benefits and
that in that mechanism is like companies
more than the kind of places or people
who live there
when i recently interviewed um gary
stevenson who's an inequality economist
he said that of everything he's looked
at and studied extensively that at the
end of the day the most effective way to
reduce inequality is through government
taxation basically a government deciding
here's how we're going to use taxation
we're going to and you know the specific
policies are of course to be discussed
but that that's really the way to do it
is your experience that that is the most
effective
yeah i think it's taxation coupled with
intense government spending and spending
by the by the federal government and by
state governments um into providing for
people so the common and that is that's
often achieved through taxation um of um
largely of the wealthy and that's really
important i mean i think because one of
the ways that this this kind of approach
and so it's really kind of um comes into
fruition in the 90s under on during the
clinton administration is this idea of
um and the clinton administration did
enact some some modest um
taxes on the wealthy but not i mean not
to the kind of full extent but the their
idea was really that you
um give corporations and wealthy people
the sort of opportunities to help rather
than actually making them make any kind
of real sacrifice and that's kind of
what taxi like a taxation approach would
do that it would reduce inequality and
in those terms and make more funding of
it money available to help people um in
need and sort of rebuild um rebuild or
should have a vibrant social safety net
so i mean i think the this next question
it's sort of like an economics question
but i think it's also a history question
and of course you can answer it in
whichever way you think is appropriate
um
when when when i hear sometimes some on
the left who they're not taken super
seriously in most cases but they talk
about a 73 marginal tax rate or a 78 on
really really high incomes i understand
the math of it and i understand the
studies about government revenue is
maximized when you have that top tax
rate at about 73 and i get it but it
also seems completely politically
uh infeasible right now
and also there's this major issue of no
matter what the rates are there's lots
of ways to get around paying anything at
all and deductions and loopholes and the
way businesses and other things are used
so from uh from a historical perspective
in terms of what's viable and what's
acceptable to populations where do you
think the democratic party should be on
tax policy
well i think there is i mean i think
what has been
um
largely popular has been this idea of
and i and i don't know the exact i can't
do the exact numbers i was
i'm terrible at math so i don't
give you or anyone else the wrong
impression but i think that um one of
the things that comes up with that is
that actually i do think that that
message of that um that corporations and
wealthy people should be held
responsible and should not be kind of um
and that goes with both sort of what
they're paying but also that those
loopholes need to be closed and i think
that actually has been a really popular
message um both um and you saw it in
bernie sanders and elizabeth warren's
campaigns and i think that that actually
that has bipartisan appeal to some to
some degree too so that is a popular
message i think when it's when you get
into the numbers probably that it's more
it's more complicated i think one of the
issues that goes to this too is that
you'd actually need with that closing
things like the corporate um corporate
loopholes and various different other
things is that actually goes to
regulation um and that's another kind of
critical piece and so i think one of the
things i looked at in the book um is the
ways in which so much of um and this
goes to kind of thinking about what
republicans and democrats have done that
especially during the clinton era there
was so much deregulation
of the financial of the financial and
tech sectors
and that's really contributed to some of
these kinds of inequalities too so it's
both
in terms of
regulation in various different
capacities that actually do force
corporations to pay more of their share
um that is a way of kind of addressing
some of these kind of major structural
inequities that exist it also seems that
sometimes it's not i don't want to say
it's difficult like people don't have
the cognitive capacity but it's just
people are busy and they have lives and
so
the idea of well let's raise taxes on
the rich okay right but usually that
means income taxes and the very rich
often don't pay income tax because
they're earning money through other
means okay well then let's raise capital
gains rates like okay well you can do
that but then instead of selling stock
you can pledge the stock as collateral
for a loan which is is another mechanism
that's used and it's not that people
can't understand these things but it's
most people aren't you know buried in
these things day to day because they're
working and so on and so forth it seems
that that also is sort of a difficulty
even when a solution is proposed that
isn't really a solution like just
raising income tax rates so there's a
communication aspect to this
yeah absolutely and i think that there's
a that's a really important point of
this is these are really complicated
things and the kind of mechanisms that
are used are hard to understand don't
sort of distill down to a sound bite and
so you can lose i mean you can um your
eyes can glaze over it just doesn't make
any sense and it doesn't seem like it's
affecting day-to-day life in various
different ways i think for the average
kind of
the average person um and i think the
other kind of piece of that too um is
the ways in which so i think this goes
to the way we think about inequality and
this also goes back to like sort of in
um my book i looked primarily at the the
kind of this period of the 90s when
there is kind of large economic growth
if you look back in the 90s with some
nostalgia of this period of like and and
so that's um that's
one of the things that happened i mean
is that you have overall economic growth
but inequality um increasing and i think
the other kind of key piece of that is
taking away these components of the
social safety net and sort of turning to
the private sector and the market to
solve those problems created a creates a
system of profound kind of vulnerability
and um and pre-predation by corporations
so that's sort of some of the kind of
the products of some of these these
issues too coupled with
huge amounts of um private personal
private wealth being amassed over the
90s but in these with other kinds of
mechanisms such to use them and i will
go back to saying i don't think this was
just this is just all of this falls
you know solely on the democratic party
um i think the republican party and the
particularly the georgia peoples
administration played a really important
role in kind of widening a lot of these
kinds of policies but i do think it's
really important to understand where the
democrats have been
complicit in many ways and and pushed
them
in um in
different avenues yeah bill clinton
you've mentioned bill clinton a a couple
of times and bill clinton will often get
arguably deserved amount of blame for
this but also i mean 1994 and newt
gingrich coming into the house of
representatives and that huge push for
deregulation and and so on and so forth
and then george w bush as well
precipitating um the 2008 recession
there seems to be a lot of blame to go
around here
i think totally and so that's one of the
things is that sort of um in trying to
kind of parse some of that out and to
sort of understand and the other thing
that i really tried to do in my book
which i think is also really important
um
are twofold one um isn't is
understanding what the democrats
and particularly people like bill
clinton and the other kind of new
democrats of the democratic leadership
council
what they um
believed in what they did um and that
and also that those are not sort of
indistinguishable from the republican
party that there are actually
distinctions in in the kinds of policies
and the reasons for why democrats versus
republicans pursue particular ideas and
that there was a genuine belief
that stimulating the private sector and
stimulating certain forms of new
economic growth and tech finance and
trade would be a mec a way to address
great forms of social equality and but
that's not what played what ended up
happening and so that's really what i've
like tried to understand through my um
through my work
last thing i want to ask about often
when i ask folks what is the model of a
country that has sort of done this
correctly
uh usually you hear countries in
northern europe or denmark sweden norway
etcetera and everybody just kind of
shrugs their shoulders and and you know
stops talking about it are those
actually the models are there models are
there successful uh examples to look at
of i don't know i've been watching so
much borgin and i feel like that's a
great show yeah i'm watching this new
season it's great it's great um i
strongly recommended it but i imagine
it's like this is incredible yeah um no
i think i mean i think that those are
always the places but i think the really
important thing about that i mean when i
look at those places is they're really
homogenous um and and traditionally and
so where social we sort of look to
these um these european countries as
kind of the um as the kind of mecca but
they've had huge issues and tensions um
over immigration and sort of who is part
of their social of their social welfare
and i think that's actually a really
another sort of critical piece of the
united states um is the ways in which
inequality sort of
becomes kind of immersed with questions
of of um
of race and how that operates and sort
of who's worthy of certain kinds of
assistance and so i do think that many
um many western european countries are
also experiencing the same kinds of
questions um today but i do think the
ways in which they've the commitments to
social spending and to having a kind of
robust social safety net um and social
well um is is critical i know and
because i know you've mentioned the the
viewers but to your um that you just had
a baby and when you look at the kind of
differences of what um
what parental and child child care are
in many um in many
um western european countries it's like
it's astounding to the difference in the
united states so on those levels i do
think there's and that does that does
contribute to forms of inequity of sort
of fundamental inequity in the united
states so i do think that there is a
place and um i mean denmark is a country
of six million people so we shouldn't
all move there but right i do have it's
like a state in the us basically yeah
yeah yeah
the book is left behind the democrats
failed attempt to solve inequality we've
been speaking with the books author
professor of history at claremont
mckenna college lily geismer really
appreciate your time today oh thank you
so much for having me on